На вулицях Барселони каталонських прапорів
завжди було багато.
Але тепер, перед референдумом про відокремлення
у багатій провінції на північному сході Іспанії,
їхнє майоріння ще більше розпалює пристрасті.
Мадрид вважає референдум протизаконним.
Та й серед каталонців є такі,
хто хоче збереження статусу-кво і ті,
хто за вихід зі складу Іспанії.
Сепаратистські налаштованих, за останніми
опитуваннями, тут близько 40 відсотків.
Аби зрозуміти пристрасті, які вирують у Каталонії,
знімальна група DW зустрілася з двома сестрами
з Барселони: Ноемі та Аріаною Сірвент.
Вони мають невеликий бар у центрі міста.
Аріана – за відокремлену Каталонію.
Ноемі хоче, щоб Каталонія залишилася частиною Іспанії.
Для обох національна ідентичність
є центральною в аргументації.
Я почуваю себе іспанкою і каталонкою водночас.
Мене не бентежить, що я маю дві різні культури,
мене збагачують обидві. І я розмовляю двома мовами.
Я почуваюсь лише каталонкою.
Я не поділяю жодних ідей, традицій чи культури,
які є частиною решти країни.
Заплановане в неділю, 1 жовтня, голосування
в Каталонії - це постійна тема розмов у сім'ях,
серед друзів та колег по роботі.
Ми в змозі розмовляти та вести діалог.
Іноді просто цілий день не розмовляємо про це.
Дуже важливо, щоб не псувались ані сімейні, ані дружні стосунки.
Ми не б’ємося одна з одною на вулиці.
Усі каталонці здатні спілкуватися і то дуже мирно.
Ставлення до референдуму щодо майбутнього
Каталонії не є чорно-білим.
В одному з останніх опитувань 4 з 5 каталонців
відповіли, що виступають за проведення
референдуму з дотриманням усіх правових норм,
який би розв'язав політичну кризу в їхньому регіоні.
Та чи є серед розбурханих національних емоцій
ще місце для золотої середини?
Звісно, є середина. Слід дозволити голосування.
Я хочу голосувати, але я голосуватиму
проти незалежності - і сьогодні, і завтра.
Незалежно від того, законне чи незаконне це голосування.
Я не вірю в незалежність.
Хто ж зарадить конфлікту?
У мерії Барселони вважають, що посередником у
врегулюванні суперечки між Іспанією і Каталонією
має виступити Євросоюз.